Kylie Jenner just cost snapchat
investors some money thanks to one tweet
while sis Khloe Kardashian is out living
her best life plus Tessa Thompson opens
up about her relationship with Janelle
Monae hello and happy Friday my friends
this is the daily Deni and if you've
ever wondered just how influential Kylie
Jenner is we now have the receipts also
I can feel the eye rolls but before you
guys comment who cares check this out
it's kind of crazy Kylie Jenner tweeted
her 24 point 5 million followers that
she doesn't really use snapchat anymore
she asked so does anyone else not open
snapchat anymore or is it just me oh so
sad
well Business Insider is reporting that
since that tweet shares 4 snapchats
parent company fell Thursday and 4 snap
skeptics who were betting that snapchat
stock would decline those traders made a
whopping 163 million dollars in a single
day sorry snapchat but if it's any
consolation Kylie did follow up with
still love you snap my first love
meanwhile Kylie's sister Khloe
Kardashian is the next to pop out a kid
and is out here live in her best life
how do I know
well a Kardashian source tells et that
the reality star who was expecting her
first child with boyfriend Tristan
Thompson has never been happier and is
ready for this next chapter quote khloe
has always wanted to be a mother and is
telling her family and friends
constantly she's over-the-top happy
adding she has a special glow about her
Khloe has been handling pregnancy gray
and continues to maintain working out
and eating as healthy as she can as
forward the LA native and the Cleveland
Cavaliers basketball star will raise
their little one our source says the
baby will be born in Cleveland but the
little fam will still live bicoastal all
right apparently a baby is also on the
way for Rachel McAdams the 39 year old
actress is reportedly expecting her
first child now et has reached out to
Rachel's rep who couldn't be reached for
comment but she is notoriously private
about her personal life and has kept a
low profile recently she even skipped
the premiere of her new movie game night
on Wednesday
I don't know about you guys but she will
forever be Regina George to me you're
like really pretty thank you
so you agree what you think you're
really pretty
a lot of Mean Girls is iconic and
fourteen years after fetch happened on
the big screen it's happening again only
this time as Tina Fey's Broadway baby
first of all I really like your hair
color is that your natural hair color
yeah shut up
how can you talk and sing at the same
time I'm talking and I'm singing at the
same time they've got there's great
performances in the movie Lindsay lon
and Rachel McAdams and Lacey and Amanda
they were they're great in the movie you
can take that fake apology and shove it
right up your hair I love to get to meet
her at some point
Kairi but what about a Mean Girls two on
the big screen I in a game for this
write it up somebody write it up I'm
actually cool if they don't do it Mean
Girls - don't ruin a good thing is all
I'm saying all right but how's this for
some good stuff it is time for my new
music Friday pics and Queen Janelle
Monae dropped not one but two new
singles off her upcoming third album
dirty computer and each of them have a
music video too but it's this visual for
make me feel that's got everybody
talking
damn that's just the way you make me
feel I mean how good is that now in case
you missed it genell's female costar in
this is thor ragnarok knockout Tessa
Thompson and someone who got the
behind-the-scenes scoop from Tessa
herself is they're very old Courtney
doesn't know look how graceful she is
thank you welcome new music Friday for a
good one exactly
I mean she's channeling a little bit of
Prince Simon and she's finally wearing
color seriously but seriously everyone
is buzzing about this video and Tesla
and Janelle and like the internet is
quick to ship people but Tessa told me
they go way back now everybody's buzzing
right now about you in the Janelle Monae
video like I feel like you're making
everyone feel like there's a shipping
going on oh my god what do you say the
fans that are shipping you in to now
that are shipping us you mean there
should be me ship they're shipping you
guys either and ship you away they're
shipping you guys as a couple this
already the fun that you guys had in the
video what do you say to that Janelle
and I have been really close we we've
been really good friends at this point I
think for about three and a half years
I'm so lucky to have her in my life I
met her at an audition um we were up for
the same part we have never been
competitive we're a huge source of
support for each other and you know I'm
so proud of her now that she's entering
the film space so what we were able to
do together for this record cycle for
her is to make what they're calling an
emotion picture and so it was so fun to
get to collaborate with her and and
Janelle is somebody that is interested
in really empowering not just women but
people to be who they are to be the food
and expression of who they are
and so the truth is if people look at me
and Janelle and these characters that we
play in the music video and have hope
people called it a bisexual anthem and
it makes people feel liberated in their
skin and
and feel closer to who they are then I
think we did our job
I think it's safe to say they succeeded
with you on that one right so there's
more of Courtney's interview with Tessa
we'll have that up for you guys at ET
online.com slash daily Danny thanks
Courtney Thank You max beyond when
Beyonce comes on that's right you're
welcome back anytime girl hahaha we do
have a couple more new jams for you guys
and this one comes courtesy of 5 seconds
of summer yes the boys of 5 sauce are
back with a hot one and how fitting that
their new single is called wants you
back
[Music]
I cannot hear the collective screams of
so many girls after that one including
on my 13 year old cousin Denise who told
me to include a new music fighter today
so girl you are welcome all right and
finally Pentatonix dropped a new video
for their cover of Camila Cabello Havana
and it's spicy
[Music]
easily
well
[Music]
they're always so good aren't they
alright guys I've done enough talking
this week but we will be back on Monday
with a fresh dose of the daily Deni so
until then like and share this video and
enjoy your weekend Havana
[Music]